auf einer judenhass hier auf
deutschlands straßen aggressive
antisemitische hetze es ist eine schande
rund 600 menschen ziehen am samstag
durch die hauptstadt
wollen sie das dort geholt wird
die grünen kindermörder israel und sie
greifen journalisten an unser bild
reporter mittendrin hier in der
hauptstadt in berlin peter wilk von rund
50 menschen dort auf dieser
demonstration hier die bilder dort
umringt zunehmend wird aggressiv er wird
als drecks jude dort beleidigt getreten
und schließlich muss die berliner
polizei sie sehen dass hier diesen
bildern ihn schützen peter wilke und ihn
raus begleiten aus dieser demonstration
das sagte innenministerin nancy faeser
zu dieser schau mal auf twitter sie
schreibt für judenfeindlichkeit gibt es
in deutschland keinen platz
das sagte bild chefredakteur johannes
boie heute in seinem kommentar auf seite
2 die judenhasser sie nehmen sich ihren
platz die polizei greift nicht durch
darüber müssen wir hier sprechen und
auch über das versagen der politik
wollen wir sprechen mit johannes wo ihr
und auch mit peter wilke unserem
reporter der von der demonstration
berichtet hatte schönen guten morgen
johannes einem morgens dieser bilder
sagst du nie wieder das ist trauriger
weise eine lüge ja leider ist es so man
hört es ja immer wieder dass das nie
wieder gepredigt wird das ist natürlich
auch richtig aber am ende muss man doch
sagen es bleibt eine sonntagsrede und
die keinerlei folgen zeitigt und wir
haben es jetzt in kürzester zeit abstand
wieder gesehen frau fischer schreibt es
gibt keinen platz für juden hast nur
stunden vorher gab es eben doch ein
platz für judenhass nämlich den
hermannplatz in neukölln aber eben auch
viele andere plätze in deutschland es
ist wohl vieles geredet tatsächlich
gehandelt wird nicht was unsere reporter
ja auch vor ort erlebt hat ist dass die
polizei im zweifel zurück weicht hier
kommen vielschichtige probleme zusammen
das ganze clans die oft auch
anti-israelische und dann in der folge
sehr oft auch antisemitisch juden hasn't
eingestellt sind die straßenzüge
kontrollieren polizei fühlt sich in
diesen vierteln nicht wohl und dazu
kommt natürlich auch dass die politik
und zwar weit überwiegend über ganz
viele parteien aber vor allem die linke
die spd die grünen es nicht wahrhaben
wollten das mit der massiven migration
nach deutschland herein eben auch viele
leute gekommen sind die in ihren
heimatländern so sozialisiert sind das
die juden einfach abgrundtief hassen für
das böse halten dass sie diese typischen
alten antisemitische stereotype wieder
mit in dieses land bringen als hätten
wir in deutschland nicht schon genügend
damit zu tun den judenhass der
rechtsextremen zu bekämpfen das immerhin
wird stark gemacht dann gibt es auch
noch den juden hass der linken es oft
politischer weniger brutal in der
handlung aber eben um so perfide und
jetzt haben wir seit einigen jahren
massiv angewachsen einen ganz neuen
judenhass in diesem land nämlich den
judenhass radikaler muslime er bricht
sich bahn in einer art und weise wie wir
uns das hier eigentlich nicht hätten
vorstellen können nicht vorstellen
wollten und die politik reagiert bis
heute nicht peter wigge unser bild
reporter dort mittendrin am wochenende
hier in berlin zwischen all diesen
menschen schilder uns einmal wer dort
war aus der demonstration also was hast
du dort erlebt wen hast du gesehen genau
wir hatten an diesem wochenende gab es
gleich zwei demonstrationen
gegen israel hier in berlin erst am
freitag und dann eben am samstag guest
vorgestern als es zu diesem vorfall
gekommen ist und bei beiden
demonstrationen waren sehr viele
menschen aus dem arabisch stämmigen
million muslime wie johannes ist schon
gesagt hat die dort eben aggressiv laut
grölend ihren hass auf israel gezeigt
haben kindermörder israel gerufen haben
israel bringt kinder um
dämonisieren israel schlecht machen und
eben dann auch judenhass ganz offen
wurde skandiert das ist ein dreckiger
jude sei sei das ist dort gefallen und
das lässt natürlich ein ganz schönes
auch in und über die täter muss man
sagen johannes wird weiterhin nicht
gesprochen wenn man auf den tweet
angeschaut der innenministerin es
herrscht schweigen wenn ich gar
schönrederei ja so muss man das leider
beschreiben eigenlob ist immer
schlechtes lob aber ich muss sagen außer
bild und nach einigen anderen medien aus
dem axel springer konzern haben auch
ganz viele journalistinnen und
journalisten hier ihren job nicht
gemacht es scheint einfach ein
ein milieu zu geben dass die meinung in
deutschland prägt im journalismus auch
in der politik dass es nicht wahrhaben
möchte was hier der fall ist nämlich
dass massenhaft zumeist junge aber auch
ein bisschen ältere muslime auf die
straßen gehen und juden den tod wünschen
und ich kann es gibt ein teil in mir der
kann diesen reflex verstehen das nicht
klar zu benennen weil man sich natürlich
sorge macht auch bei der deutschen
geschichte
führt das zu ausländer hass wenn man
eine gezielte gruppe so klar benennt und
kritisiert wie jetzt in diesem fall
radikale muslime aber ich denke wir
können es uns als gesellschaft überhaupt
nicht leisten über diese probleme nicht
offen und klar zu sprechen und auch die
menschen da draußen darunter übrigens
auch viele
fantastische und vernünftige muslimische
bürgerinnen und bürger in deutschland
fragen sich warum wird das problem nicht
klar beim namen genannt was ist da los
und noch ein anderes beispiel ist es bei
der auch vor ein paar tagen brannten in
schweden ganze stadtviertel in flammen
gesetzt von jungen muslimen die eben
auch oft mit völlig anderen
aggressionspotenzial in demonstrationen
gehen und einige medien in deutschland
haben darüber berichtet als hätten
rechtsextreme diese viertel in brand
gesteckte richtig an der geschichte ist
dass rechtsextreme zunächst eine
provokation verursacht hatten was
natürlich verurteilenswert ist was aber
auch irgendwie von der meinungsfreiheit
gedeckt ist soweit ich das mitbekommen
habe und das so lange wir die probleme
nicht richtig benennen werden sie weiter
existieren und es ist ein fehlschluss zu
glauben dass die jungen männer die hier
mehrheitlich auf die straße gegangen
sind und [ __ ] usw brüllen nicht
mitbekommen dass die innenministerin es
nicht schafft ein klares wort dazu zu
finden die er kennt sich in seinem tweet
doch gar nicht wieder dieser tweet ist
geschrieben von der innenministerin als
ging es um
irgendwelche politiker die sich im ton
vergriffen hätten oder
rechtsextreme die irgendwo was
antisemitisch gesagt hätten und solange
das problem nicht benannt ist wird das
fortbestehen und man sieht ja dass es
von jahr zu jahr wächst denn diese demo
sehen wir jedes jahr oft auch an von
iran ausgerufenen al kuds tag eine
veranstaltung die einfach nur dazu dient
das rund um die welt muslime ihrem
judenhass freien lauf lassen können das
wird hier immer wieder verboten
herumgeschoben aber wirklich etwas
verändert hat sich das nicht wir sehen
diese bilder immer immer wieder die
demonstration werden größer der hass
brutaler juden verlassen deutschland das
ist eine schande lass uns noch mal peter
in diesem moment rein tauchen dort am
wochenende
wir haben nicht dort gesehen raus
begleitet von der berliner polizei durch
so einen korridor dort durch diese
wütende aufgebrachte schimpfende juden
hassende menge jetzt bist du persönlich
beschimpft worden es gab auch insgesamt
diese parolen immer wieder gegen israel
gegen alle juden in der welt was
passiert eigentlich wenn du dort raus
begleitet worden bist von der polizei
mit diesen männern die all das gerufen
haben hast du das weiterverfolgen können
gab es dort entsprechende festnahmen hat
das konsequenzen wenn man hier in berlin
auf der straße ja aktiv sein judenhass
zeigt es gab auf jeden fall vor ort
schon festnahme ist selber konnte die
nicht mehr sehen weil ich musste den
ordnern verlassen es wird einfach zu
gefährlich aber die polizei hat auf
jeden fall männer schon festgenommen die
eben beamte angegriffen haben außerdem
hat die polizei auf wir können das jetzt
ermittelt wird wegen volksverhetzung
genau eben wegen diesen aufnahmen die
zeigen wie ich dort als drecks jude und
scheiß jude beleidigt werde und außerdem
wurden auch die während der gesamten
demonstration schon die gegen insgesamt
zwei stunden viele andere journalisten
auch angegriffen ein kollege von mir hat
einen tritt gegen den oberkörper
bekommen also die stimmung war gegen
israel sehr aggressiv hassen gegen juden
aber auch gegen medienvertreter weil
diese menschen nicht wollen dass gezeigt
wird mit welchem hast sie auf die straße
gehen hier in berlin was ist die
konsequenz dessen johannes
bild-chefredakteur heißt das beim
nächsten mal schicken wir peter dort
nicht mehr hätten schicken wir keinen
reporter mehr dorthin können wir nicht
mehr so darüber berichten nein das heißt
auf keinen fall bild reporter sind mutig
unter hart im nehmen und peter ganz
besonders sich dank ihm auch sehr für
seinen einsatz dort vor ort vielleicht
denken wir aus sicherheitsgründen mal
drüber nach jemand anderen zu schicken
dass es hinter der kamera zu besprechen
aber natürlich schicken wir weiterhin
unsere reporterinnen und reporter exakt
dorthin wo es wehtut dafür steht bild
und was die konsequenzen der politik
betrifft kann ich nur sagen dass die
fehler unsere migrationspolitik in den
letzten jahren dringend korrigiert
gehören denn ist es mittlerweile einen
dermaßen vielschichtiges problem
entstanden dass man mit den einzelnen
ermittlungsverfahren der polizei
das problem nicht bei der wurzel packen
wird sagt johannes wo ihr bild
chefredakteur und auch herzlichen dank
an peter wilke unser reporter der vor
ort war am wochenende beim nationen
dankeschön danke euch